another indiscriminate attack on
ukrainian civilians while they slept
where to begin for these rescuers in the
rubble of people's lives
as they search for survivors the number
of dead continues to climb
one side of this five-story apartment
block was completely leveled in the
attack
and dozens remained trapped
i used to know all the people who lived
there i was told that one child was
killed there was only one family with a
child it was arena with her
nine-year-old child so we came to find
our neighbours maybe somebody already
left i don't know
chassis yar is just 12 miles southeast
of kremertorsk a key ukrainian
stronghold in the eastern region of
donetsk
the russian offensive is now focused
here after its neighboring province
luhansk fell
while russian ground forces rest and
reorganize they've intensified shelling
of their new targets
civilians here are bracing for an
onslaught
i would advise you to listen to the
donetsk governor and leave evacuate
because no material things are worth
human life we will rebuild everything
everything will even be better but we
need people to return to the de-occupied
cities afterwards
russia maintains it is not targeting
civilians in this war but those words
feel increasingly hollow
another apartment block and two
campsites were hit in the southern
region of odessa last week killing at
least 21 people
the week before at least 19 people were
killed in a shopping center in
kremenchuk
it's understood the same anti-ship
missiles fired here were also used in
odessa
weapons that are inaccurate and reckless
for use in urban areas
the region of donetsk is now in russian
sites
this may just be the beginning of the
horrors for towns like this civilians
living in fear
even at home in their beds
knowing nowhere is safe
sally lockwood sky news keefe